all right so we don't usually do real
thoughts immediately after a certain
review but after hearing his thoughts on
it I feel you really deserve it yes yes
we need to talk about Jem and the
Holograms because I'm very excited to
talk about this and I know you are too
I'll let you go first because I'm why
don't you say what you said after you
saw the movie well one that's two hours
of my life I'm never getting back uh one
of the top I'll go with top ten but it
may enjoy top five I'm gonna say you
know I'm and still say top five it may
have nudged things like Blues Brothers
2000 and some of the other ones out top
five worst pieces of shit I've had to
sit through for watching than the static
like an idiot you just knew it in my top
five it's it ah most cynical half-assed
piece of corporate whoring shit I know
you know what I said I turned you summer
in the middle of moving I'm like this
makes me want to smack every millennial
I see like anybody that yeah Annie but
yeah anybody about the age of 25 or
under I I just wanted to punch them in
the face even though they didn't go see
this nobody wants to sell and I realize
it I realized that that is unfair to
Millennials yeah you even said you said
the movie is unfair time away it's
unfair the Millennials because it makes
you want to punch every last millennial
I've seen the face cuz there's nothing
but a slew a string of slanderous
stereotypes
launched at an entire generation that
not only pisses on the cartoon show
shits on it but then like eats it
regurgitates it and then shits it on an
entire generation younger than us and
that generation Millennials cuz I have
known that I lack of a better term I
know what the hell we call them I
they're just as much the victims in the
so my apologies I don't really want to
punch every last money I'm just saying
that's what this film did to me that's
why how this film represents you people
yeah
god it's weird being at that age where
we can find just shout shit at like you
know a generation younger than us one
Willy there's of course gonna be pros
and cons but it's like I feel like we
have a lot of dirt shit there's like Jem
and the Holograms and there's no witness
out there you can - masterpiece compared
to this one though yeah no no but I'm
saying like you know and but I I know
what you're saying that when you watch
this you feel like oh like this is what
they're trying to hit this is what
they're trying to sell to and we've had
plenty of that in our generation - again
look at the later Disney Afternoon stuff
and the 90s I did you'll get it um but
really we've had anything as bad as this
in the 80s though because when I think a
really shitty things aimed at children I
was thinking the 90s I'm trying to give
us there anything down here kids I think
what but that was not like aiming at an
age group that was just you know didn't
hit Canadians I somebody was asking this
is like well where's his regular Garbage
Pail Kids I'm like oh it's close yeah
it's very close because at least Garbage
Pail Kids
to its credit had nothing to shit on
what's goodness
it's shitting on a bunch of like trading
cards that were meant to be discussed I
really shit on cinema just the art of
cinema could be yeah could be
but in a still had nothing to ruin it
didn't it didn't ruin a perfectly decent
like cartoon ship one of the few I like
okay decent decent I thought if okay
it's a masterpiece and it's like new
iPhone case t-shirt but would you rather
watch gem or Rainbow Brite like
typically people drive have those
amazing villas oh yeah but Jim had the
misfit that it's true I I got okay or or
the original the original before they
clump all over our faces accessions say
there's any way
now the original the original my love
I'd rather watch Jim the original my
love Wayne Allen that's it actually
probably watch the new Michael O'Neill
friendship but it so yeah um I'm trying
to think if we had something in the 80s
as cynical as this as
bottom-of-the-barrel bottom-feeding like
I mean I will have to wait till
Ghostbusters comes out because I'm like
thinking there's the only thing I could
think of that could compete with this
we're just the ultimate but even then I
looked at the tracer among at least it
looks like they they tribe in some
respect there's like at least there's a
budget at least I like could recognizes
like okay it's it's ghostbusters whether
or not it's good Ghostbusters I guess
I'll wait and see but I mean even from
the trailer though I'm just like okay no
there is no way this could be good
there's at least human activity with the
ghosts and stuff like that yeah I'm like
we want no creativity like not nothing
new nothing interesting this is all as
the go to the Ghostbusters trailer light
okay I don't think this really looks
good but I'll wait and see maybe the gem
trailer is like oh no this is 100% shit
there is nothing no no there is no
recovering from this like yeah you know
and here's the funny thing about this
one this and he'll tell you all
throughout this movie when it was done
and everything I loved watching this
movie I adored watching it I don't know
why cuz it would usually around grab the
TV controller from your hands and beat
you would usually do that the other way
around because you know your wife
watches a lot of rom-coms and chick
flicks like bad ones knows their bed and
has fun watching them and I can't stand
those so it would kind of figure that
you would like this more and more but I
found it really funny it was human
ironically badvel like good like bad
rom-com yeah I thought it could laugh at
the pattern and the the ridiculous is it
like I couldn't even laugh I'm just like
this is just so sad and pathetic but not
even funny sad but I guess I can just so
see the corporate you know formula you
know like let's get this down to a
mathematical form though these are the
things to do and just no case
no passion they did he weapons west
trying to do nope none but that's what
makes it even funnier there is no
passion or interest in it at all it is
clearly just given what the chart says
you know the finisher most it is like
yours
I can't even chart guys oh no is the
budget for the review uttered I feel it
is no usually hard film that's why I
thought it was just a huge lab the only
part where I got legitimately angry as
it shows in the review as well is when
they're taking the videos of the fans
talking about the cartoon and we have
the video that says talk about the
cartoon you know out there it's online
so nobody could excuse and say Rossum to
sing for something else and they put it
to this piece-of-shit movie I thought
that was very very demeaning coming I
felt like that that scene in The Truman
Show with a little hankies and there's
like he's gonna drown and he doesn't
even care I just like this is this
movie's gonna suck em II don't even care
they have no idea they have no idea and
yeah I think oh yeah something see it I
didn't like the show growing up I try
watching you know bits of it again for a
while I was doing the review I'm like no
I feel stupid
finally I've made it through B then
between I'm pretty sure our cousin was
into it because I feel like you may have
been too young to remember I feel like
we're all at once it was on the
background then I had a friend who had
like two sisters and they watch it so in
the background I've seen probably all
together like in our daycare and so like
that or at least he didn't wait I don't
know I didn't watch it um I didn't like
hate it or anything about it's like I'm
not going to act like no this is you
know I'm a fan and I'm too mean no no no
no this is oh no nothing that is a weird
thing this is I didn't watch the fucking
show but I was still in so if you're
going to bring the show you know to the
movie especially saying hey talk about
what you love about the show we'll put
it in the film uh you know you have this
responsibility to bring something
something that ready
you can't just say that's energy Oh boom
your gem you know it doesn't work that
way you have to have some idea for these
I'm sayin some carry it there's just no
caring a for the source material and B
for the fans
I'd be very curious because I was trying
to read up on it I was like I was having
a Daffy Duck moment my course
responsible for this like I want to find
the Bugs Bunny drawing this scenes
fucking with me and I and I was
horrified like if what I'm reading is
correct it was made by a fan a male fan
really yeah now that does not seem I'm
not I'm not I'm not judging it anyway I
mean they're male fans of Joe I don't
get oh no no no not that it was a fan at
all but I rub hair leaf and all who had
been trying to get this off the ground
okay for a number of years and Hasbro
finally agreed but I I'm very curious
who is responsible for what decision
because I would assume that this is
Hasbro shitting all over a generation of
girls just to you know try to get
something out there with their brand
name on it uh um but I but apparently
this guy like wanted to make like this
movie apparently here that the story
goes as I read now Wikipedia may be
wrong I don't know but he's wrong yeah I
know he was a fan of the show through
his like sisters or something
and he didn't like the show originally
but he became a fan of it and he had
decided that he was going to make but if
that's really his vision his if that's
his vision and not Hasbro's
of course you what kind of a fan of the
show he was yeah I like I I kind of
doubt it why I'm sure anyone that would
say that decide to get this movie going
this can't be this can't be the film
they thought they were gonna make or
that they wanted to bring to the big
screen doesn't make us guys look at know
um I don't want to be one of those guys
like well only a girl could direct Jem
and the Holograms but I mean this was
not good evidence and I don't believe it
I think anybody of any gender could
detective you know any woman could
direct a great entrance in life but the
fans but this did not help our case
stands on those videos some are men
summer
boys and stuff Maya Kenny and those
people could have made a better job
movie than what we got um and yeah I
mean I think to me because I didn't I
didn't like the show growing up but I
still acknowledge there's this
responsibility you have when you make a
film like this called this title and you
had to bring something of some it's got
like a huge cone fund like my wife loved
the show apparently like her mother was
like calling the local station out in
Michigan when they canceled did she ever
see the movie
no she'll watch the version she saw the
trailer and literally like looked at it
as my wife could only say yeah fuck that
and then left the room well I I think
Jill I remember I came out Julian was
posting all this stuff about cuz she was
not a big surprise a huge fan of it and
just like you know just all this stuff
like what the hell is this what the fuck
is that I think I even feel like a
Facebook post that just showed like the
poster it's just interesting to litter
to cross town s is Gemini I mean that
really is it it's glitter chasin cartoon
it it didn't appeal to me but then a lot
of the boys cartoons into people to me
either so it's just like I just liked
what I like that around a judge um yeah
I would neither of hurdles most men
perfect in between us it was
action-oriented and it was created
earlier turtles in the Real Ghostbusters
- yeah I did like he-man for Skeletor
never matched earlier yeah I never
watched it for he-man yeah and I always
want the opening of Thundercats and then
get really bored but I guess there's
like crazy but we're never eccentric I
was ever into the show but I get white
girls like then I get why guys may enjoy
it it's like it's not a bad it's your
own thing that that age group so to just
destroy it not now here's a question for
you how cuz I was really thinking this I
was thing like well how would you do a
gem in the Holograms movie now and the
only way I could think to do it would be
come as sort of like how they did the
Brady Bunch movie or like Legos embrace
the insane reach the height of these fun
of it but look they could be in zone 2
your own own it I mean or Jeff
all grants morally unapologetic just go
insane and they want to greet it what is
this I have to go see it cuz it looks so
crazy you want a great example of how to
do it even though I don't think that
film did it right but I think it was
much closer to getting ready Joe seeing
the Pussycats do that film only
correctly hmm like I know what I heard
bad things like it's not good things but
mostly fanfic it's not it's not good but
you can see where there were good ideas
in it ah only it's all those zooms that
it's like oh well we're gonna make fun
of the whole like music culture in the
way that they're all corporate whoring
but then have all of these like product
place yes that's why I got it it's is so
it's one of those things where I'm just
like okay no you fucking cheated and
this kind of fails but I'm like I like
the idea behind what misses try even
though I could not even do the comedy to
trying to do it serious like the big bad
musical corporation wants to sell out
their art and stuff in this very obvious
music or sell out film yeah that has
nothing to do with the original source
material they talk about being true to
yourself true to your heart when you're
not even true to the source material and
it is just I don't know it's like I
understand that some things you have to
change if you make a film you got to
change some stuff I get it but you know
it strange song about it's not all the
stuff but even when you change things at
least make it a lateral move don't make
it stupider yeah I thought the whole
synergy think I'm like so this guy
creates artificial life practically and
like she's worried about her fucking
singing career
so that fucking BAM no it's the whole
time there's a million things I put it
out at the end I was like how would you
like to be like gems little sister dad
induce it for her this is all a gem I'm
gonna send you on this personal journey
without my sister never mentioned gosh
she wasn't in the room when that message
was read because she would just kill
herself right there oh my god I
my dad didn't love me my dad created
life for something Sherrie created like
hey I'm life
you made me but I'm so glad the first
one made you create robotic life to sing
songs and green hologram puppet shows
yay
boom idling I feel like Melissa's like
Tina from Bob's burger but at least I
got this my little pony yeah yeah the
the plot made no sense
um I can't even to be fair I was looking
up the like the story for the Jim
cartoon cuz I was like why does she have
to disguise herself in the cartoon I was
trying to go figure out there's really
no reason like in the cartoon and that's
all the thing to got in this there's no
reason there's not even a way she's
discarded ears in this really it was a
fucking cartoon meant to be a fantasy
this try so desperately to ground itself
and like reality it's like oh we're
gonna fucking why do I have to see where
they're going based on Google Maps this
whole film's obsession we trying to
cater to Millennials of the neck see
we're using smartphone favorite thank
you fell Fifi we're hip we're hip by our
shit
I would like to point out by the way of
hate that I would like to point out that
Rob Scallon who is in the movie has
never seen the movie yeah he said that
he got paid for his clip you know and it
was fine everything my drums waved my
life he pretty much said I've never seen
this film I've heard too many horrible
things I have no interest so uh but he
did the kill I'm sure you watched our
review of it for the Cameo oh but uh
yeah in my opinion my personal feeling
this I think if you just find this stuff
really funny these kind of really force
used to be about the music man just done
to the worst hilarious possible level I
think it wasn't that Errol arias I
thought it was because I wanted to see
the manipulation and these actors trying
to do eye crease performances and see
that so what I was alone it's like
watching uh it's like was a quack tack
on the Disney Afternoon it's like that
it's just so obvious and so forth but
more effort when it's a quack pack that
went into this high agree movie but like
that's really what happens even funnier
to me this is zero effort zero like
nothing I love watching that the main
girl um you know playing gem just you
know trying to do the voice you know and
just talking like because you know she's
kind of mellow
and every time so sad tears oh you like
how those YouTube likes to shut up like
yeah we have one night yeah cuz I tried
and what it's like it's not even a great
before it's just like there would be
when those things are Mike if somebody
shared that with me on my facebook I'd
be like who gives a fuck
slide what if I roll I'm yeah I mean
it's like why why would this goes okay
the funniest bit in this movie I swear
just watch it again I try to play it
like you know I'm really angry in the
review but when the guard sees the
squirrel on the jet skis just as haha
guys guys come over here it's a squirrel
you knew he had to know that was a
stupid line and he was just having fun
with it - God cover it's a girl like you
do me know yeah it's worth it for the
one guy and the squirrel but I'm just
saying like I don't even know that was a
performance like hey I really want to
sell this it's like he had to know
there's no way to say this where it'll
make sense so I'm just gonna really have
fun what's what's happening man I
thought it was hilarious like to my fans
so I see you will defend eyes wide shut
doctor legitimate I know that this is a
shitty rant against something like
Jurassic world and then be like now gym
in the hoenn oh no no it's it's awful
but I love how I think it is so
entertainingly awful Thomas oh is Orson
fucking wells compared to this I I love
it I I think when it got to the point
where lights I wouldn't recommend it to
anybody unless he is so good it's been
so bad it's good movie but yeah I I know
this is this is so bad it's bad I I like
the storm with them I wasn't you have to
be you have to be in the mood to see
something very particular um I think it
is that kind of that that kind of film
were just you can feel them indicating
the manipulation all over it so in the
three minutes we got left here uh any
last words to say about this one of the
worst pieces of shit I've ever had to
sit through and I will say this the
funniest thing I got out of it was
showing Spoony the trailer and just yes
him staring there and he just he stares
I know now that's a I was
as I Jimmy's I've seen this I've ever
seen the choice that's not you you can't
do that
yeah that's what I said they can't do
that I'm like well I think they do but
they can yeah they can you isn't pure
denial she doesn't even care about the
show that we just said over an hour to
the book you can't do that you can't no
you can't you can't if they are but you
can't but you can
it's Larry then no that's that it's
against law you can't he just was so
adamant just like button and like us I
mean he did really care that much about
the show but he just knows that is so be
to be tried as so betraying the fan base
and the people that made it pot you know
popular uh so yeah it was uh I'll never
forget the look on his face like he
watched somebody gets shot he just his
eyes is open is oh oh oh killed me so um
yeah that's our real thoughts on it just
I think you can figure out whether or
not this is something you want see
because it's so bad or skip because it's
so bad uh but yeah I went understand
either way so guys that's about it and
the truly truly truly outrageous not a
truly truly truly pathetic sellout piece
of fog like this ville by sham is my
name something like that